headline i don't want my wife to become
a stay-at-home mom
before the baby she was ambitious what
happened dear karen feeding i'm a new
father of a beautiful 10 month old girl
my wife's company has a generous
maternity leave policy
and she has been at home with her
daughter since the birth
and is scheduled to go back to work just
after her first birthday in january
but she recently told me she doesn't
want to go back to her job
she would like to be a stay-at-home
parent instead then he goes on about i
was trying to convince her not to do
that
he says one of the things that i was
most attracted to was her ambition and
tenacity
it's really surprising to hear that her
career isn't that important to her
anymore honestly i don't want her to
quit her job she earns about the same as
i do and while we could make ends meet
on any on my income alone
it would impact our ability to save and
we'd need to give up one of our cars
and cut back on extras that make life
more enjoyable
i also just don't want a stay-at-home
wife i really admired
her work ethic and i want her to set a
good example for our daughter too
seeing her give up like this is give up
like this
is really disappointing what should i do
signed
suddenly the breadwinner what should i
do
what should i do to quote
the godfather when he has asked that
very question by johnny fontaine
you can act like a man what's the matter
with you
what's the matter with you what man
are you this is the husband who wrote
this letter
this is putatively the husband who wrote
this letter
so many things wrong with him
his wife has this daughter and she has
the audacity
to want to raise her own daughter and
you see this is not ambitious
if the wife goes to the widget factory
and types all day
on her keyboard and just does
spreadsheets you know and makes widgets
and well she doesn't make the widgets
but
you know she's sort of supervising the
the people who have outsourced the
widget making to the and she so she's
doing that that's really ambitious
but raising a human being it's like
whatever whatever we can you can just
hire someone to do that you see what
this guy wants to do
he wants to send his wife to work for
another man
so that she can make money so that he
can pay another woman
to raise his child because that's that's
the way it's supposed to work
that's ambitious otherwise you know if
the mother doesn't want to do this
she's just she's giving up and keyboard
this guy i mean i get it i
i share his outrage
he's suddenly the breadwinner i mean he
makes plenty of money but he might not
be able to buy a new car next year
suddenly the breadwinner it's like that
this selfish
woman expects her husband to provide for
his family
can you imagine that while she
raises his child
gosh what a what a selfish woman
what a lazy selfish woman to to want to
raise her family
and uh to want her husband to work and
support the family
this dude is everything wrong with our
culture
and even the perception of it i mean
maybe he comes by the perception
honestly
that raising a family is somehow giving
up or it's lazy or it's not ambitious
the hand that rocks the cradle is the
hand that rules the world we used to
know that
we used to know that a a
mother with her child is the
center of the world of this world that
we're all living in is the absolute
center
everything else that we do in this
material world in our economic life
all of it exists to serve that not
everybody gets to have children it's
actually hard for a lot of people to
have children for some people they don't
get that
option but
we can cast oh it's nothing let's just
let's pay somebody else to raise our kid
that's the economic model that i don't
mean just to beat up on this guy i mean
this guy is truly a schmuck he is a
girly man as we say you know it reminds
me of the distinction between womanly
and womanish woman lee is a woman
acting in a way that is proper for a
woman to act
right it's not an insult it's a
compliment oh she's so womanly oh my
gosh
when a man acts in a way that it is
proper for a woman to act
it is there's nothing admirable about
that because those qualities
are corrupted they're perverse they're
wrong it is womanish
so when you call someone a girly man
it's not an insult against girls
it's an insult against that guy because
he's acting in a way that is so perverse
but but he's he's doing something that
our whole culture is doing and it's not
just the left it's not just the left
though they sort of instigated it
in especially in the 1970s saying that
the only values that matter are manly
values and women need to be forced to go
out and work
simone de beauvoir who was one of the
most famous
feminists ever i guess
and was also ironically the jilted
common-law wife of a notorious
philanderer the philosopher jean-paul
sartre
uh one time simone dubois was having a
debate with betty friedan
over feminism there's two prominent
feminists and friedan said yeah women
want to work good if we want to stay
home good and before said no
we can't give them that choice we have
to force women to work
because if we give them the option to
stay at home they'll take that option
and that is not conducive to liberation
the left believes that and the right
believes that
the right you know there are some
proposals now to incentivize having
families because we have a dying
population and a birth rate below
replacement
and so some people i think i think rubio
is the one who did this said
we're going to incentivize work romney's
plan of direct payments
to families who have kids that's that's
wrong we need to incentivize work we're
the party of work
no i think that if a woman
wants to raise her family that's a
really good
wonderful thing that should be
incentivized by society we should not
force her to go out and work in the
widget factory there's nothing
conservative about forcing women
out of their homes to pay some other
woman to raise their kids
so that they can go work at the widget
factory and get a paycheck that is
a totally perverse ultimately
liberal left-wing view of mankind
viewing mankind is primarily an economic
actor rather than
what we really are which is complex
people with complex relationships born
into families born into communities
who appreciate beauty who serve god who
have more going on for them than their
paychecks
my my only advice i guess would be to
this woman which is are you sure you're
you sure you've made the best choices
i'm not saying leave your husband but
you know maybe smack him around a little
bit get him to uh get him to shape up
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button so everyone waiting
through the wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
[Music]
[Music]